[Music]
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
I'm your host Jared aka the man with the
chainsaw and Boomstick and in this video
we're going to be going over the ending
of Evil Dead rise I'm just warning you
bring an extra pair of pants but in this
breakdown we're going to be going over
the plot themes post credit teases other
Evil Dead Staples along with our
thoughts of the movie be prepared
because heavy spoilers is reading
straight from The Book of the Dead so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend you close the
book now but please do hit that like
button and make sure to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day with that
out of the way thank you so much for
clicking this again I am Jared now rise
any
meaning
you alright so evil dead rise actually
starts with a pretty sick cold open of a
group of friends on a secluded camping
trip very reminiscent of the other Evil
Dead cabin settings as the camera
quickly zooms through the forest like
the spirit of a deadite but it's
actually a remote controlled drone we
soon realize that one of the girls on
this camping Adventure is acting erratic
and is already possessed by a dead eye
ripping the scalp from her cousin and
drowning her boyfriend in a cloud of red
murky Lake water she then elevates out
of the water with a big ass letters of
Evil Dead rise coming out of the Horizon
as the title card hell of an opening
then boom bam one day earlier text Pops
on screen so yeah these camping teens
aren't even who we're focusing on as we
are then introduced to one of our main
characters Beth living the life of a
grungy metal band guitar technician or I
guess groupie finding out that she is
pregnant this shocking Revelation sends
Beth to her sisters Ellie living in a
condemned apartment building in Los
Angeles her her three children and a
couple others are living on the top
floor of this joint which is set to be
demolished in a month Beth and Ellie
have a bit of a strained relationship
you can tell that they've had to kind of
raise themselves was because their
mother wasn't the best because surprise
surprise there's an underlying theme of
motherhood flowing through this movie
expecting mothers established mothers
and I guess abandoned mothers again this
is an uneasy relationship Ellie sends
the kids out to grab some Za as her and
Beth catch up with Beth learning that
Ellie and her husband split and she
wasn't there to help Ellie through this
tough time a sisterly Bond theme also is
kind of thrown in here but as the kids
are coming back with the pizza from a
place called henrietta's Pizza a nice
call back to Evil Dead Two I think
there's an earthquake that structurally
breaks some of the foundation in the
parking garage below the building Danny
Ellie's son finds a small hole has been
created leading into an abandoned bank
vault below the building in here he
finds some vintage vinyl records and
unbeknownst to him the Book of the Dead
director Cronin mentioned that this book
is actually different from the original
book and the one that was in the 2013
reboot claiming that he likes to think
that this third book was the one that
was featured in Army of Darkness that
when Ash finds the three anyway Dany
takes this all up to their apartment and
like any dumb teen opens the book after
accidentally dripping blood on it and
playing the vinyl records there are
three in total with the first featuring
priests finding the book and arguing if
it is safe or not with the second record
is where things get a little dicey
essentially a demon voice begins to read
from the book causing a dead eye to find
its way into the apartment building
possessing their mother Ellie in the
elevator now the elevator sequence looks
very similar to the tree root sequence
from the older Evil Dead movies with
wires twisting her body Urban
environment creativity working here
people as Ellie is now possessed while
Ellie is being you know a little sus
[Music]
some of the other neighbors on the floor
are established here all worried because
Ellie's elevator ride Tower of Terror
instant blew out the power to the
building now it's basically your Evil
Dead trapped in a cabin but trapped in
an apartment series of events with Ellie
attacking everyone they lock her outside
of the apartment where she terrorizes
all of the Neighbors in a really really
Kick-Ass hallway peep hole sequence
however bad news Bridget Ellie's oldest
daughter got some blood in her via a
tattoo gun and is now possessed this is
where things turn into a demented
version of Adventures in Babysitting as
Bridget tries attacking them but Cassie
the youngest jams a mop handle through
her mouth and head yeah she had taped a
doll head to a mop calling her
wait for it Stephanie pun game is
unmatched from this little one Ellie
trapped in the hallway Bridget is dunzos
for now so Danny finally comes clean
about the book and the records so Beth
steps up into the motherly role and has
a listen to record three while listening
she realizes that the priests had tried
everything and total body dismemberment
was the only solution perfect they know
what to do but Ellie had snuck through
the vent now in the apartment teaming up
with Bridget who is now back up walking
around Danny sacrifices himself to save
the youngest Cassie as Beth and Cassie
make a break for the elevator grabbing
the neighbor's shotgun in the process
shooting one of Ellie's arms and legs
hashtag family is in full effect Dominic
Toretto would be proud as the possessed
Ellie Bridget and Danny morph into what
I can only describe as the Rat King from
the last of truly horrifying John
Carpenter type
the deadites caused the broken elevator
to fill with a blood drowning Beth and
Cassie as it hits the maximum weight
limit and crashes down to the parking
garage harder and messier than the
Kool-Aid Man bursting into your living
room the pair tried to leave via car but
the monstrosity halts the car they try
run into the open gate only for Cassie
to be captured at the very last second
Beth now in full on protective mother
mode goes back in shooting that some
beach with the shotgun and picks up a
yellow beige Chainsaw embodying the
essence of Ash Beth revs that puppy up
just tearing through the mutated alien
kids forcing them into a wood chipper
painting I'm telling you up just
smearing that whole parking garage red I
mean this is some but Boom the deadites
are gone as Cassie and Beth head off to
hopefully brighter Futures with Beth now
being prepared for Parenthood and sort
of being the ash of this hopefully new
series of movies but you remember the
group of friends from the opening yep
the final minute or so shows one of the
women living in the same apartment
building different floor seen the
Carnage of the parking garage she's
attacked by a rogue deadite and then
heads off to the camping trip that we
see in the beginning of this movie so we
can only assume that someone somewhere
is still possessed and where they wander
well your guess is as good as mine but I
will say this makes me not want to ever
watch someone's children
now if you're wondering if Evil Dead
rise sets up a whole big Evil Dead
Universe hashtag edu
um well no that there's there's no post
credit scene so it's okay to pick up
your trash and get out of that theater
but there is a brief sound effect of a
fly buzzing around at the very very very
end of the credits similar to that of
Iron Man's Hammer at the end of end game
now this isn't necessarily a setup but
more of a tease of a potential what if
and with the way that the film was
structured combined with the fact that
this is a really bang-up horror movie
I'm sure positive reviews and box office
numbers will be the main indicator of
whether or not we see more of these
deadites and helpless people in the
woods or condemn Department buildings my
money my money right now is on more so
uh fingers crossed of course another
thing hardcore Evil Dead fans are
probably curious about is if Bruce
Campbell AKA Ash Williams with his
Kick-Ass chainsaw Boomstick and groovy
catchphrase make an appearance and the
answer is no uh Sorry Charlie Bruce
doesn't bring the camp Bell in this one
who's this man
however if you are listening closely his
voice does make a cameo as one of the
priests on the vinyl records that are
played when Dany discovers the Book of
the Dead I think one of the trailers
actually has a little bit of audio I'll
put it here if that's the case the book
of the day if not my bad uh I'm sure
people are wanting more Ash but Campbell
says that he officially has unofficially
retired from the character after the
cancellation of Ash versus the Dead
series but there's a small smidgen of
Hope because a couple weeks ago director
Lee Cronin mentioned in an interview
that Campbell's priest character was one
that could very well be Ash Williams
just displaced in time from the events
of Army of Darkness so grab your
chainsaw because things could get
groovy
honestly I am not the biggest fan of uh
horror movies maybe I'm slowly getting
there but holy hell was Evil Dead rise a
claustrophobic tense bloody I mean
bloody ride of a horror movie I really
enjoyed the different setting and the
reasons for why there are only a couple
people here or there seems plausible
like it all makes sense in this Urban
setting but man this was like a gruesome
version like I said before Adventures in
Babysitting sure the scares are there
with the camera movements adding to the
creep Factor but I appreciated the
Twisted comedic sequences just as much
and yeah I said bloody this is full on
Bloody director Cronin said that they
used something like 6 000 six and a half
thousand liters of blood so grab your
swim trunks and flippy floppies for this
one I'm throwing a solid 8 out of 10 at
this latest Evil Dead installment it has
a lot of things Evil Dead fans will
grasp onto but the way that this movie
is pun intended bookended the cold open
is great and wonderfully sets up
everything while the ending is a full on
mashup of John Carpenter David
Cronenberg and the Rat King from The
Last of Us ultimately it's a story about
mothers and expecting mothers and the
metaphors are really reinforced here the
only small negatives I have are some of
the delivery from some of the teens and
children and anyone looking for any in
your face connective tissue to other
moments in the Evil Dead franchise like
ash for example I mean the chainsaw's
there but he's not are going to be left
out in the cold anyway I'd love to hear
your thoughts on Evil Dead rise was this
one of the scariest most gruesome movies
you've seen in 2023 and what would you
like to see in this updated landscape of
the Evil Dead franchise and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
the Ant-Man onto Mania movie on the 15th
of May and all you got to do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video make sure to subscribe and drop a
comment down below with your thoughts of
Evil Dead rise we picked the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so that's you message
us on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch be sure to
check out some of our other cool videos
sneak peek we have The Exorcist coming
soon stay tuned for that but with all of
that out of the way thank you so much
for your constant support I've been
Jared I'll see you in the next one take
care and peace